[Music]
welcome back to CBS morning's Memorial
Day weekend is almost here and so is
vacation inflation AAA says more than 42
million Americans will travel 50 miles
or more this weekend at our airports
alone nearly 3.4 million people are
expected to fly to their destinations
this holiday weekend that is up 11 from
last year Chris Van Cleef spoke to
Travelers about the high cost of getting
away he's on the road in Chicago Chris
good morning how are the roads looking
well Vlad we're going about five miles
an hour so I think those 37 million
people that AAA expects to be driving
for Memorial Day are all on the Kennedy
this morning we know that traffic's
going to be heavy that can cost you time
on the road getting to where you want to
go but going anywhere this summer is
also going to cost you more money
Kelsey Elizondo and Isaiah Wright hoped
their pre-memorial day vacation would be
a money saver but heading home to Salt
Lake from Atlanta they're feeling the
pinch of vacation inflation
how expensive it is
prior to kids and we felt like we could
go anywhere even on a budget but with
their one-year-old and four-year-old in
tow the costs added up fast how much
more did you spend do you think
[Music]
yeah I'd say probably another probably
another two thousand dollars more than
we thought in April airfare jumped 2.7
percent from March while it's down
slightly from last summer it's nearly 10
percent higher than it was before the
pandemic hotels are up 3.5 percent from
last year and up 15 from 2019. car
rentals will likely be cheaper this
summer down 11 from last year but remain
51 higher than four years ago vacation
inflation is huge this summer we're
seeing high demand and travel and with
that we're seeing high prices Sally
French tracks vacation inflation for
nerd wallet so people should expect to
pay more for their travel than they have
in even the past couple years
35 percent of Travelers told nerd wallet
they've opted to drive instead of fly to
save money with gas prices more than a
dollar lower on average than last year
we met Jacob rash filling up this RV at
a Bucky's in Georgia for 285 a gallon I
didn't think gas would be that much of
an issue but I've almost spent like a
thousand bucks and we didn't go
within 2000 miles you know it's crazy
and the cost to do things on vacation
that's up too food away from home jumped
nearly nine percent from last year 24
from 2019 movies and concerts will cost
you about seven percent more than last
year what we went in thinking we are
going to spend versus what we actually
spend is crazy
AAA expects traffic like this to pop up
in country cities across the country
starting around 3 P.M today similar
story on Friday so if you're looking for
the best time to leave watch CBS
mornings today and tomorrow and then get
on the road right after Vlad
that's a good plug Chris uh and it's
early morning and it still looks like
it's slow going uh Chris Van Cleef for
us on the road in Chicago Chris thank
you thank you Chris bye